I just got on the ground and he was like
saying thank you Whitney for being
honest Kurama Brown praises Wendy
Williams for opening up about her
struggles with addiction you know I've
had a struggle with cocaine in my past
and I never went to a place to get the
treatment he caught up with the queer I
star while on the red carpet at the US
premiere in NYC where he had nothing but
love for the talk-show host
recently revealed she sought treatment
for drug abuse and is living in a sober
house I was just watching Wendy Williams
today talk about her drug abuse and her
battle with addiction and I in my book I
talk about my addiction to cocaine and
how it was rough and I just think that
anybody could come forward and speak
their truth like like when I saw that I
just got on the ground and it was like
saying thank you Whitney for being
honest thank you for being open because
she's gonna save lives and that's what I
hope do in my book I sent her flowers
but you know it goes to whatever person
you know it goes to like I don't have
her personal information that I was long
her so the other day I'm distinct fell'd
that she's open and honest because she
has a big Platinum platform and if more
people would come forward I think we
would have less celebrities and just
everyday people feeling as if they're
alone in their addictions gramo also
dished on the fab 5s buddy Pete Davidson
and his budding romance with Kate
Beckinsale we're all friends repeat and
I'm just happy that Pete has found
someone new that he could be in love
with you know I know that the break-up
of Ariana was hard and so I'm just happy
that he's in love big step because he
was dealing with mental health issues
after the breakup and the fact that he's
found support he's also found someone to
love him you know I just want to say I
would encourage him you know like to
take a little slow but you know I think
he's so brave
listen heat you're always welcome you
want to mean like he's on a list of
people we love Pete's great